à l'approche de Noël ce sont 100
millions de colis qui vont transiter par
la poste mobilisation générale pour
l'entreprise en Indre-et-Loire qui
recrute notre invité nous en parle
bonsoir Emmanuel David bonsoir vous êtes
directeur de la poste de Fondettes qui
est également une plateforme de tri pour
l'undre et Loire leur Noël est toujours
une période très intense pour pour vous
donnez-nous un ordre d'idée de cette
activité
et bien je peux vous parler de la
journée d'aujourd'hui pour vous donner
un ordre d'idée la journée d'aujourd'hui
qui fait suite au week-end du Black
Friday c'est voilà le qui est le
week-end qui lance cette période c'est
le double de colis que ce qu'on a un
mercredi normal ça se compte en dizaines
de milliers
c'est pour faire un chiffre assez simple
c'est aujourd'hui nous allons vous
distribuer sur l'agglomération de Tours
10000 colis donc ça s'accélère pardon
juste après le Black Friday et pour ça
donc vous recrutez 65 intérimaires pour
faire face à cette accroissement
d'activités à partir de quand et quel
poste sont concernés alors on a déjà
commencé notre groupement vous vous
doutez bien on a encore quelques
justement quelques recrutements
possibles les profils c'est ça que vous
me demandez
les types de poste alors c'est
principalement des livreurs à 80 90% des
facteurs et des facteurs livreurs de
colis en particulier et puis on a aussi
une partie qui sont des
manutentionnaires qui nous permettre de
faire vider les camions trier les colis
et les les données sur les bonnes
positions pour qu'ensuite ça puisse
partir en livraison et pour un mois
c'est ça à peu près la période à peu
près environ donc c'est quoi le profil
des qualités requises finalement pour
travailler alors les profils recherchés
il faut déjà avant tout des gens qui est
le goût de la relation de proximité de
la relation humaine du contact client
puisque nos livreurs nos postiers mais
les ceux qui viennent les renforcer en
période sont aussi face aux clients et
doivent répondre à leurs questions
doivent leur téléphoner pour pour
optimiser les livraisons donc on cherche
ce type de de profil et puis quelqu'un
d'autonome et d'organiser qui suivra une
formation de cinq jours c'est bien ça
tout à fait une formation de 5 jours
avec une formation liée à la sécurité
parce que ce sont quand même des postes
où on confie un véhicule d'un certain
gabarit pour ce qui est de la plateforme
de Fondettes on a une mécanisation du
tri donc il faut la connaître et puis il
y a une formation plus technique sur les
processus de la poste et puis un
accompagnement directement avec un
postier pendant deux jours généralement
le salaire il est de quel ordre le
salaire l'embauche à la poste pour un
poste de faxor c'est
22000 un peu plus de 22000 euros par an
brut c'est 10% au dessus du SMIC pour
les intérimaires c'est le cas aussi
c'est le salaire qui est de base ensuite
il y a les il y a aussi ce que font les
entreprises de travail temporaires c'est
quoi une journée type justement à la
poste en période de Noël alors les
journées type de la plateforme de
Fondettes qui distribue qui traite 60%
des colis du département c'est un début
à trois heures du matin une fin à minuit
et demi et puis ça s'articule autour de
8 équipes qui Quitterie qui décharge et
qui prépare les tournées et qu'il est
distribue donc il faut être prêt à
affronter les horaires atypiques c'est
celui des clés notamment un dernier mot
sur la crainte des vols de colis
toujours à l'esprit des clients comment
vous faites pour combattre ce problème
alors il y a deux sujets dans votre
question il y a ce qu'on sait faire nous
c'est à dire augmenter la sûreté dans
nos plateformes lors de nos transports
avec bon on a amélioré tout ça notamment
parce qu'on trace beaucoup plus les
objets et puis il y a le sujet des vols
dans les boîtes aux lettres ça on a on a
moins de comment dire moi la main dessus
évidemment mais on agit avec les
remontées de nos clients les
réclamations et tout de suite son
informe les facteurs et les facteurs par
le biais du téléphone c'est ce que
disait ils appellent leurs clients pour
leur dire voilà je suis là mais j'ai
plutôt vouloir remettre en main propre
ou vous le laissiez dans un endroit de
votre choix un bureau de poste un relais
pick-up pour assurer quand on a ce genre
de choses une livraison pour postuler la
poste un dernier moment on fait comment
sur la poste.fr et puis voilà
directement et puis on travaille que
quand même aussi avec beaucoup
d'entreprises de travail temporaire pour
cette période merci beaucoup Emmanuel
Emmanuel rapide directeur de la poste de
Fondettes